intense preparations are underway for
next week's summit between the president
and North Korean leader Kim jong-un in
Singapore officials are working out a
series of details and in the middle of
all that North Korea says a separate
meeting with Syria's president is now in
the works which a Jang is also at the
White House we should good morning good
morning nor the wide range of logistics
US diplomats are negotiating include
everything from where the leaders will
sit to what they will eat to who will
pay for North Korea's hotel rooms since
the country is cash-poor
the State Department says it will not
pick up the tab meanwhile we are waiting
for president Trump's reaction to that
North Korean state media report that
Syrian President Bashar al-assad plans
to meet with kim jeong-hoon back in
april the US and European allies
launched airstrikes against Syrian
military targets as a response to a
deadly suspected chemical weapons attack
last week Kim also met with Russia's
foreign minister meeting president Trump
said he didn't like a positive sign
ahead of the summit was North Korean
vice chairman kim youngchul
delivering a letter from kim jeong-hoon
to the oval office Friday but the
president still lowered expectations
saying the summit is only the first step
toward denuclearization now before
President Trump heads to Singapore he
will attend the g7 summit in Canada
where all six other world leaders will
urge him to reconsider those newly
imposed tariffs on steel and aluminum
imports amid fears of a trade war John
we Joe thanks